nelle puntate precedenti di residenti ma
eccolo ok non ho più pure quindi o
spiazzo schiatti chi è che sta arrivando
non ho la chiave era è stato così
semplice azionari così la corrente solo
questo devo fare porca di una vacca che
è che che tutto sto casino per la
scatola ci fa ridere sta roba
perfetto apriti wow ma strobo quale lo
devo controllarmi che c'è qualcosa
dietro chiave elettronica posso andare a
lucky è una chiavetta è una chiavetta
usb ben chiaro chi non ha le chiavette
così comode tascabili l'aspetto che ci
aspetta è difficilissimo il fatto che
non mi ricordo ben fermi zitti ricorda
vedi qua ricarica veloce prima che vi pd
lo zio qua
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti che ti lanka ultimi speriamo
let's groove sei anni per e 3 qua dentro
però non ne sia valsa la pena o una
lighting hoc per trovarla ci ho messo
sei anni quindi immagino sia veramente
forte ragazzi è il momento di andare al
parcheggio let's go allora fatevi sotto
schifosi ora aprirò mille e celle tra
cui un miliardo di zombie che si
liberano tu stai fermo siamo arrivati
salve adesso tibero tranquilla dove
mettete i primi cosi che pirla 1 e 2
aspetto
vabbè ho fatto cose
bene non so non so cosa ho fatto ok non
mi serve la tesi grazie tessere perché
ho amen
allora ragazzi questa roba non funziona
bomba di jolo bene strike dio mio
tutto adesso sto su tutto e vabbè ma
dove uscita al muro poi è bravo
investino investito per favore grazie
secondo me si è fatto male solo il
cambio tutto questo ha posto grazie ad a
sono st mi sa che anche lui è stanco
adesso ecco spagna
secondo me adesso è morto però non è
detto e morto va bene lo zio quindi è
morto devo ufficialmente non vorrei
andare a controllare ma parte che
sparito non ci va bene si sei tranquillo
calmati tutto sto casino proprio una
serranda figura io comunque mi sta un po
cagando addosso perché secondo me non è
normalissimo che stiamo riuscendo ad
uscire così quindi ci ha fatti proprio
uscire in strada a figo o se entrare qua
dentro ci sono delle munizioni
vabbè allora fai quello che vuoi passare
per quelle cose ci stavo entrando io
però non vanno mai pagato canna lunga
attenzione sì ho visto ci dobbiamo
passare in mezzo al cantiere wow dritti
nelle fogne
sì ma siamo noi gli stiamo andando
proprio in bocca l'umbrella corporation
e sotto terra a quando dice le fogne e
sembrano posto adattata alto sto morendo
prova aspetto che mi colpiscano un'altra
volta poi mi curo la vacca che ansia
siti che qua è una zona delicata
che diavolo
e un coccodrillo grosso del problema se
dobbiamo morire moriamo bene ecco magari
non nella fogna che schifo sicura che
sia suo nome lei non si butta e troppo
chic per bagnarsi tipo la impermeabile
così aspetti che c'è un coccodrillo
gigante lo faccio fuori poi scendi ok
devo sei sicura volevo proprio rimanere
qua io che strano anno lo devo far fuori
corre basta a e tipo crash bandicoot è
diventato vetus capital cosa che sta
arrivando a dio non mi ha preso per
niente vero
ma tu ecco magna del gas non ritorno di
portanova
una bomba esplode a posto e morto solo
fortissimo ma dai mille verrei di qua il
prima possibile
però è stato un bel combattimento lo
ammetto tutti si è goduta lo spettacolo
di tutto questo è stato è stata la boss
battle più [ __ ] nel mondo
non ho dovuto fare niente se non
lanciare una bomba aveva detto che il
virus trasforma le persone in gol prima
non i rettili anche io non ho capito
come ci è arrivata lei qua
ok diamo allora net smettiamo di creare
virus per cortesia che visto che ci devo
combattere io non è che siamo qua siamo
praticamente andando l'umbrella c'è un
casino per arrivarci
fermato e sei marce
siamo qui per il virus chi va beh la
fermi prima che scappa pure ci manca
solo che se io sia felice lana di
smallville e rega uguale adesso deve
impersonare lei a caso a caso nuda senza
un motivo
si va la domanda è una sola ecco perché
è ok a [ __ ] tutti i miei le cose che
avevo tutte cioppi niente beh fantasti
grazie parlando di follereau
dall'accesso sotto una comunque sta
pistola qua mi fa piacere che tu l'abbia
tirata fuori solo dopo che io ho fatto
un casino per uscire dalla stazione di
polizia perché se potevi controllare
l'elettronica potevi aprire la serranda
che schifo gli scarafaggi mamma
direttamente questa perfetto
sono proprio la tipa fiammeggiante
questa battuta la rigida vero se tutti
al city spacco tutto o nove colpi ciò
jam hanno tolto tutto l'inventario o
nove colpi gli os precati tutti per far
fuori te speriamo che li ion torni in
fretta il suo gioco perché grazie no
adesso da me li adesso è che gli ospiti
tutti e nove porco demonio schifoso
morto possiamo evitare di giocare con
questa ancora per molto mi sta veramente
sul diretta guarda lì
guarda di di zombie è pure quello stava
pregando la mecca sono questa tipa era
tutta una [ __ ] ci sembrava veramente
fortissima la controllo io fa schifo a
tre colpi non la vita non ha niente se
non questa roba che controlla e robe
elettriche tranne quando servivano è
quella lì non la controlliamo per carità
sono anche dove sto andando a ecco la
lurida pezzente d'altro il vetro sarà
prova di proiettile figure sempre ancora
quanto cioè mettere no a rega non ci
credo sia per la porta porco schifo
mamma mia quanto ci ho messo lei però
c'è però quanto tempo non so dove aiuto
non so dove andare
non so dove andare non so dove andare
non solo andare perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto non fate
domande ragazzi non lo so forse scende
addirittura preciso non è scelto bene mi
sono salvato in una maniera incredibile
e non ho neanche idea di come ho fatto
fantastico allora cosa attivato ormai
attivo le robe non sono anche che sto
attivando ma se devo disattivarla la
corrente perché se adesso è attiva io
prendo con la farem incenerisce però
proviamoci lo stesso perfetta adesso ho
detto quello che volevo non succede
grazie zia
quindi complimenti dai live e non lo fa
disattivare aiuto eccoli qua basta che
non mi vanno a fuoco i piedi in tutto
questo a devo farlo in tempo
non ho idea di cosa sto facendo va bene
grazie scemi o impossibile non sono
anche questo palazzi maniaci all idolo
disattivare tutti ok mi sa che ho capito
un po tardi quello che devo fare peccato
perché c'ero quasi che si che in onda
che culo che colori credibile
ce l'ho fatta pensavo di non aver fatto
in tempo incredibile va bene mannaia
quella zoza è veramente forte la tipa
cioè nel senso minimi frega in tutte le
situazioni però ma c'è una boss battle
quanto ci fate che non ho tra l'altro
colpi ne niente quindi devo farla senza
agorà
si fa tutta la [ __ ] quando le
cinematiche per con me fa schifo è morto
quasi zelo ricordarsi sarebbe meglio c'è
pure qualcosa qua sotto ci scommetto lo
devo fare una boss battle senza una
gamba
oppure comando leon leon eccolo fatto
riposino achievement è sbloccato donna
misteriosa grossi fascisti giocando alla
rim e spiega mi sa da dove andata
non lo so no ho attivato la corrente
quindi adesso funziona
chissà dov'è adesso farò tutto un altro
giro immaginano dai un'altra volta nelle
fogne
ormai ci ho fatto la vita gare anche in
the last of us navi così tanto nelle
fogne il cielo eccolo prova a fare il
girona
mi sa che il giro non lo facciamo però
intanto tiene il coltello te lo regalo
bene non lo so via
che schifo il mondo ci mancava solo
questo guarda ma ora c'è la m
sotterraneo una funicolare una
funicolare sotto terra
non sapevo neanche questo termine
funicolare si imparano sempre nuove cose
da residenti vol
non sono io che sono scemo acqua dove
c'era la zia era lì ad aprivano o
sbaglio sì che ha fatto giro esatto
quindi sono molto più vicina data di
quanto pensi allora come ci esco di qua
è un enigma
io me ne intendo un sacco enigmi prendi
lo spinotto col cavallo tra l'altro a è
un enigma dove deve infilare gli
spinotti molto semplice a valence
perfetta apre già molto bene
ecco nelle fogne non ci tornerei tanto
volentieri perché ci sono quegli affari
schifosissimi e tra l'altro che
discettano tipo quello quindi le noci
dalle balle eccolo lì salve buongiorno
domandiamo scappa scappa esplorato la
granata
io filate un coltello una granata sta
fare ora sono tornato dove c'era da
prima quindi normale se non fosse che se
ci saranno eccolo lì
non l'ho visto mi sono salvato per
miracolo perché niente più quegli affari
per favore perché basta non ho capito
ragazzi devo andare fermi di stoccare de
son di unipol aiuto nelle fogne e poi mi
do per la meno nel distretto di polizia
e carino da vedere non nelle fogne e
vabbè allora forse devo andare di qua ma
non ci sono ancora stato però pensavo
fosse una roba limitata invece no forse
devo andare veramente di quanto stai
ferma per favore perché mi serve ma è
sempre peggio
sto giocando a residenti vallona kirby e
in the amazing universe e non sono a
casa esistere non l'avevo visto però ok
non indietreggia neanche
ok mercato un po di colpi prova va bene
ma ora che impossibile
ok no mia ho rischiato e non regga
imprese c'è troppa gente c'è troppa
gente
madonna ha sprecato un milione i colpi
non quello lì
vabbè ho fatto veramente un casino
fatemi salvare che se muoio riparto da
casa di dio tra team in corso per
salvare per favore c'è divo tarc soldo
riformi tutto tutto devo rifarmi sono un
salvo lo svuotato un caricatore a quel
tipo di non sono anche se servito a
rotta a lo spinotto la torre non c'è uno
spintone dato ancora di trovare la
chiave gola del distretto di polizia
eccolo qua ti serve un'altra torre wow e
non ho la torre porco demonio allora
fammi capire acqua c'è un'altra torre
fermi tutti no questo nella torre il re
schifo
ce la farò mai la prima volta qua perché
ci vuole lo spirito sbagliato così
signori grazie mille grazie a tutti
effetto non ho ben capito che con che
spazio un lanciafiamme veramente wow
grazie lo accetto proprio di buon grado
lanciafiamme grazie mille gentili niente
prendi questo anche la torre se riesci a
wright allora signori it enigma prime
dopo sei anni sono tornato qui prima se
riesco a fare sta facendo acqua devo
allora hai detto se non sbaglio la torre
il cavallo sono sullo stesso muro ok è
l'alfiere la reggina non sono uno
accanto all'altro la reggina l'altra
invece sono i lati opposti quindi la
torre il cavallo sono sullo stesso muro
qua c'è il cavallo vabbè questo abbiamo
capito che dobbiamo metterlo qua ma
potrei anche cambiare le torre cavallo
per la li non ci ho pensato proprio così
e ti vedo di questo non so fare
a capi di così non potevo fare guarda va
bene quindi se state cercando le
soluzioni online fa vige come ha fatto
la stanza e pedalare
reggina pedone alfiere torre cavallo ho
pensato io per voi grazie prego
ciao a white tie and dye l'aveva sono
dall'altra parte del west disposto e ma
scusa mi sentivo qualcuno qua dietro
come è possibile
scommetti che uno di quei quelle mail me
pero giganti sicuramente una di quelle
melma enormi ma sicuro
m lab ecco io non se la pecca da boe ha
posto questa la mettiamo qua un'altra
volta va bene
ormai sono esperto di ste cagate perché
non so come ho fatto proprio da me
strano però sentivo dei versi o fa
dietro sicuro charlie scommesso dato
quanto esplosivo
io non posso continuare questo gameplay
ve lo dico è che cristo dico eppure
eppure io non devo parlare devo stare
l'hack è male porto demonio male fatto
malissimo
a bari ci mancava solo questo non
esplodono non esplodono mamma mia
ragazzi che disastro non esplodono i
cosi niente di quello che faccio va come
vorrei perfetto la storia della mia vita
cioè altamente infiammabile si barili
gli tiro lanciafiamme non esplodono ok
banco ma che sei un pelo forte quindi
secondo me se mi tocchi muoio
ma tu no nel nostro porto ma è un boss
questo senso devo farlo per forza fuori
non si fa niente questo è sua schiena
nella mano a si è fatto bene poi è il
momento i soci è ben capito il suo
rifare ma vabbè così hanno aspetto forse
ok andato giù non va giù beh adesso
ok preferito
sono muore adesso me ne vado speriamo
che stai macerino siano finite sua da mi
ha creato perfettamente la strada per
andare via
wow ho giocato il pochettino questa
volta però soprattutto quando ho dato
fuoco alle cose che infiammabili che non
sono esplose a ok ciao ada ho passato
l'inferno è satana compreso per vedere
non c'è più eppure non so se il fallo
non posso camminare così bene farà male
beh pensavo peggio io urlavo molto di
più agli esami del sangue
dobbiamo andare al nest investa il
laboratorio sotto di noi ne parlava
nette
i campioni del virus solo li senti
non credo di avere altri impegni beh sì
c'era l'altra ragazza che era veramente
più carina ancora di questa però vabbè
andiamo con questa per strada io sono
morto mille volte però vabbè io tanto
ormai so già che lo so a memoria dove il
caso per il successo passa sei volte
tutti i tagli che ho fatto che voi non
vedete
ok la funicolare alla funicolare
accompagniamo noi va bene allora non c'è
niente da capire
faccio io non ho l'autorità una sola non
ce la faccio l'unica speranza che ho per
chiudere il caso non ti posso
abbandonare se ti attaccassero se avesse
bisogno
cosa volete che dica l'unica persona che
esce dalla franzone quest'uomo grazia
appena chumby cp del grosso 8 volte il
mio dei capelli ordinati non sai neanche
come si chiama di cognome alle sue ci
penso però faccio io zia te preoccupà
quindi
questo era il terzo episodio di
residenti vo spero vi sia
però vi sia piaciuto quanto devi giocare
al momento mi piace anche vari sono il
comitato descrizione se non siete
iscritti ancora iscrivetevi e non ci
vediamo
ciao
[Musica]